dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on effect this paper
is about creating stunning cloth
simulations that are rich in your to
yarn contact normally this is a
challenging problem because finding and
simulating all the possible contacts
between tens of thousands of interlinked
pieces of geometry is a prohibitively
long process also due to the many
different kinds of possible loop
configurations these contacts can take
an awful lot of different shapes which
all need to be taken into consideration
since we are so used to see these
garments moving about in real life if
someone writes a simulator that is off
just by a tiny bit will immediately spot
the difference I think it is now easy to
see why this is a highly challenging
problem
this technique optimizes this process by
only computing some of the forces that
emerge from these yarns pulling each
other and only trying to approximate the
rest the good news is that this
approximation is carried out with
temporal coherence this means that these
contact models are retained through time
and are only rebuilt when it is
absolutely necessary the regions marked
with red in these simulations show the
domains that are found to be undergoing
significant deformation therefore we
need to focus most of our efforts in
rebuilding the simulation model for
these regions look at these results this
is unbelievable there's so much detail
in these simulations and all this was
done seven years ago in research and
technology this is an eternity this just
blows my mind the results are also
compared against the expensive reference
technique as well and you can see that
the differences are minuscule but the
new improved technique offers four to
five times speed-up over that for my
research project I also run many of
these simulations myself and many of
these tasks take several all-nighters to
compute if someone would say that each
of my all-nighters with now count as
five and be absolutely delighted if you
haven't subscribed to the series please
make sure to do so and please also click
the bell icon to never miss an episode
we have tons of awesome papers to come
in the next few episodes looking forward
to seeing you there
thanks for watching and for your
generous support now see you next time
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you